[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels ich habe vor kurzem eine ganz
besondere einladung zum backen bekommen
und zwar zum backen in der pfalz und
denkt jetzt vielleicht mensch warum ist
das beste was besonderes aber die
einladung kam von einem sos kinderdorf
eben der pfalz und bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
habe ich mir irgendwie noch nie so
richtig gedanken über sos kinderdörfer
gemacht also klar man hört immer davon
ich wusste dass es welche in deutschland
gibt und auch im ausland auf der ganzen
welt aber im prinzip konnte ich mir nie
so richtig was drunter vorstellen was
sos kinderdörfer überhaupt sind und was
dort passiert und was da gemacht wird
und ich hab sie besucht und war wirklich
sehr positiv überrascht und möchte euch
da jetzt einfach mal ein paar bilder
zeigen
[Musik]
dieses familiärer dass die kinder
wirklich familien haben man gibt viel
und man bekommt auch zurück und das fand
ich einfach nicht rein so was tolles
ausbilder
das macht mir einfach freude und ich
habe das angefangen und bin immer noch
dabei
[Musik]
ich wurde von der lieben irene in das
sos kinderdorf in eisenberg in der pfalz
eingeladen
in den sos kinderdörfern ist es so dass
eine kinderdorfmutter für sechs kinder
zuständig ist mit ihnen lebt sie dann
zusammen in einem haus und jedes kind
hat in diesem haus ein eigenes zimmer
hier sehen wir heike funke sie ist darf
mama von kindern im alter zwischen drei
und zwölf jahren
und sie zieht bereits die zweite
generation der sos kinderdorf kinder
groß mit fast allen kindern der ersten
generation die eben bei aufgewachsen
sind haben sie auch noch kontakt sie war
früher industriekauffrau und erfurt dann
von einer freundin vom sos-kinderdorf
[Musik]
seitdem ist wirklich ihre berufung und
heike ist schon über 20 jahren
kinderdorfmutter ich bin an sich zufall
hier aufs kinderdorf gestoßen und habe
als familien helfen dieses damals
gearbeitet anderthalb jahre und hatten
einfach wahnsinnig gut gefallen weil ich
das einfach nur unheimlich sinnvolle
arbeit finde die kinder zu betreuen
wirklich womöglich von klein auf bis sie
erwachsen sind und ihnen einfach ein
zuhause zu geben mit unseren kinderdorf
mütter bieten wir an dass man bei uns
beziehung zu menschen aufnehmen kann
dass man sich an eine person binden kann
und das ist oftmals für diese kinder das
beste das wichtigste
und genau das haben wir hermann maier
ist der gründer der sos kinderdörfer
er wollte nach dem krieg den kindern ein
zuhause geben die die eltern im krieg
verloren haben
heute ist es aber wirklich so dass es
kaum noch waisenkinder sind die in den
dörfern leben da bei uns zum glück kein
krieg herrscht und es auch keine
naturkatastrophen gibt und wenn hier mal
ein kind verweis durch einen tragischen
autounfall zum beispiel dann werden die
kinder meist auch von anderen
familienangehörigen aufgenommen die
meisten kinder in den sos kinderdörfern
haben heute noch leibliche eltern und
die können sich meist aus
wirtschaftlichen sozialen oder auch
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht
ausreichend um ihre kinder kümmern und
die entscheidung für eine unterbringung
im sos kinderdorf trifft dann das
jugendamt
denn jedes kind in deutschland hat recht
auf schutz und auch auf gute
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
die kinder brauchen zunächst einmal
einen ort an dem sie tatsächlich sicher
sind sicher heißt dass sie auch sicher
im tagesablauf sieht in der struktur
dass sie wissen hier wohne ich hier ist
mein zimmer hier ist mein bett hier
bekomme ich will dich versorgt
tatsächlich einfachsten sachen für die
kinder es ist wirklich sehr wichtig dass
sie auch den kontakt zu den leiblichen
eltern unserer familie haben und die
kinderdorfmutter die sorgt dann dafür
dass das möglich ist
meine alle eltern
der kontakt ist mal mehr mal weniger
intensiv
also ein kind geht relativ regelmäßig
zur mutter zu besuch
die anderen bekommen regelmäßig von den
eltern besucht und ja und dann gibt es
halt einige die auch nur einfach
telefonischen kontakt haben es ist
wirklich unterschiedlich die größeren
kinder die gehen in eisenberg in die
schule und für die kleineren gibt es
drei verschiedene
betreuungsmöglichkeiten
hier können auch kinder aus eisenberg
die einrichtungen besuchen und seit ein
paar jahren gibt es beispielsweise den
waldkindergarten den ich ganz besonders
toll finde weil die kinder da das ganze
jahr über den wald jeden tag aufs neue
entdecken können und einfach frei in der
natur sind die kinderdorfmutter geben
den kindern sicherheit und schutz und
die kinder wissen dass sie dort gut
aufgehoben sind
dort werden sie vielleicht auch zum
ersten mal in ihrem leben in eine
familie aufgenommen
sie lernen den umgang miteinander sie
haben ihre gewohnten rituale und die
menschen um sich herum denen sie
vertrauen können
die kinderdorfmutter lebt gemeinsam mit
den kindern in einem haus und ist
wirklich rund um die uhr für sie da sie
wird unterstützt von einem erzieher und
einer erzieherin die die kinder auch
fördern unterstützen und fordern um ihre
stärken weiterzuentwickeln und auch
kompetenzen auszubauen
15 jahre hier fällt ich viel besser hier
gibt's was was du an der hecke besonders
mag ich hierauf können hat benjamin kam
mit nur einem jahr ins sos-kinderdorf
[Musik]
ich finde toll dass mal wieder gefasst
im sos kinderdorf gibt es verschiedene
pädagogische projekte für die kinder da
gibt es zum beispiel paula das ist ein
therapiehund und mit ihr wurde ein
projekt entwickelt in dem die kinder ihr
selbstbewusstsein stärken können bei
meinem besuch haben mir die kinder auch
zuerst einmal die tiere gezeigt
wir haben gemeinsam die tiere gefüttert
und gestreichelt und der umgang mit
ihnen ist wirklich sehr wichtig denn so
lernen die kinder auch verantwortung zu
übernehmen
in verschiedenen schichten sind sie für
das füttern oder auch fürs saubermachen
zuständig sie können mit den tieren
schmusen und eine beziehung aufbauen
auch der körperkontakt ist sehr wichtig
viele kinder können sich so auch öffnen
und verraten den tieren auch manchmal
ihre intimsten geheimnisse und so können
sie einen zugang zu ihren gefühlen haben
für uns ging es nach dem händewaschen
dann mit unserer leckeren backaktion los
[Musik]
schoko muffins und jetzt 45 kids und
farben wie lila madeleine den mich und
den anthony war haben die land- oder
merken können und wir starten jetzt auch
gleich denn ich glaube alle hunger auf
süßes oder eine haben schon gewaschen
obwohl ich nicht so schön geschrieben
das ist richtig toll vorgelesen
[Musik]
300 gramm nutella
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zu welcher fast voll mit ihr darüber
und wir drücken okay
[Musik]
und einige frische
sag ich jetzt mal wieder im man daraus
machen kann neben zu ein bisschen krieg
super lecker und dann könnt ihr euch zu
einem keks nehmen
das ist dann diesmal von rudolf so frau
und den mund in harmonie
[Musik]
nach dem backen haben wir gemeinsam eins
meiner videos angeschaut und da saßen
die kinder wirklich ganz fasziniert vor
dem bildschirm und haben mir so
aufmerksam beim schminken zugeschaut
in dem video habe ich nämlich gerade
sanierer als folge
[Musik]
war wirklich sehr schön der besuch im
sos kinderdorf und mir fiel der abschied
auch wirklich sehr schwer und ich habe
den kindern auch versprochen dass ich
sie mit sicherheit aber wieder besuchen
werde
die weihnachtszeit ist ja auch eine
große spenden zeit überall sind die
scheppernden dosen und jeden tag hat man
in anderen brief mit einem spendenaufruf
im briefkasten und natürlich deswegen
weil natürlich viele gerade zur
weihnachtszeit auch gerne helfen möchten
auch ich habe ganz viele kommentare und
nachrichten gelesen von meinen
zuschauern die mich gefragt haben
menschen die wo kann ich denn helfen wo
kann ich hin spenden hast du eine ganz
tolle aktion und ich denke mit dieser
sos kinderdorf aktion kann man wirklich
was gutes tun und wirklich ganz vielen
hilfebedürftigen kindern einfach dabei
helfen ein zuhause zu finden und einfach
damit sie gut und behütet aufwachsen
können
die sos kinderdörfer gibt es ja wie
gesagt nicht nur in deutschland sondern
auf der ganzen welt und die hilfe kommt
wirklich da an wo sie dann auch
gebraucht wird und ich denke wenn jeder
einen ganz kleinen teil dazu beiträgt da
können wir alle gemeinsam wirklich was
ganz tolles bewirken und ihr habt auch
im film gesehen diese ganzen wunderbaren
kinder die wirklich ohne das sos
kinderdorf vielleicht gar nicht die
möglichkeit hätten ebenso wohlbehütet
aufzuwachsen und falls ihr jetzt auch
gerne helfen möchte und mich bei der
aktion unterstützen möchte
dann schaut doch einfach mal unter dem
spendenfonds danach das verlinkte ich
euch unten oder dem video und ich würde
mich wirklich sehr darüber freuen und
ich denke ganz ganz ganz viele kinder
werden euch allen sehr dankbar sein und
ich hoffe dass ich das video gefallen
hat gerne dürfte ist natürlich auch
teilen und damit so viele menschen wie
möglich dass videos sehen und auch
mithelfen können
und ja jetzt wirklich sehr viel spaß
gemacht die kinder waren wirklich alle
wunderbar die einrichtung was super
schön und hat wirklich alle alle
erwartungen übertroffen
und ich war wirklich total positiv
überrascht und ich denke dass auch ihr
wahrscheinlich jetzt einfach mal gesehen
hat wie so ein sos-kinderdorf aussieht
und ich wünsche euch jetzt noch allen
eine richtig schöne weihnachtszeit und
habt viel freude mit eurer familie mit
euren freunden und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal